I think it's entirely unsupported by the
text and the history of the 14th
Amendment this provision was written
after the Civil War of an actual
Rebellion Trump has not been charged
even with incitement
Harvard's law professor emeritus and
constitutional scholar Larry tribe and
his Pals at CNN must be fans of the
angle because they were watching the
other night when guest Jonathan Turley
took issue with tribe's position that
the 14th Amendment provides a way to
keep Trump off the ballot
Mr Shirley doesn't know what he's
talking about the fact that there was no
charge of incitement no no in no
conviction that's not the point if you
engage in an attempt to overturn the
government you shouldn't be entrusted
with power again it is conservatives
like judge ludig and members of the
Federalist Society who agree with me I'm
afraid that Jonathan Turley is basically
a hack
hack
I go Larry needs to look in the mirror
personally I think being called a hack
by a so-called legal expert who once
accused Bill Barr of shooting protesters
with rubber bullets in Lafayette Park
and who supports Court packing being
called a hack by him is a huge
compliment Jonathan Turley George
Washington University law professor Fox
News contributor joins us now uh
Professor Turley
um your response
well you know I suppose I'm supposed to
now engage in trash talking because
that's how this goes right this is the
license of the age of rage and rage is
addictive and Professor tribe shows that
addiction you know there was a time when
law professors could simply disagree and
really argue the merits tribe is a
signature for attacking people I got off
light he uses vulgarity uh against you
know conservatives that don't share his
opinions and I frankly I just think that
that is a tragedy for our profession but
on the merits here what he is suggesting
is not just wrong it's dangerously wrong
you know as I say in a column in the New
York Post in response to that attack
tribe has often been wrong on these
cases the courts rejected him over and
over again I mean the California Supreme
Court rejected one of the bills that he
said was constitutional unanimously that
was the California Supreme Court now
does that mean that his views aren't
Worthy they know I of course they're
worthy of consideration but we don't
have to do ad hominem attacks my problem
with the 14th Amendment is what tribe
and others are suggesting is that this
is self-executing you don't need a vote
of Congress so 50 states could have
litigation against Biden against Trump
some could bar him here and some could
borrow them there and we would have
utter Madness the fact is that this
amendment refers to Insurrection and
Rebellion or Rebellion
it comes back to what January 6 really
was was it a an Insurrection now my
point about has not been charged with it
is only because we don't have a vote of
Congress and without that vote you would
think that there would at least be some
objective basis yeah who gets to
determine it yes this was clearly a
direction right yeah I mean that's the
whole point here yeah that's why it's
hackery to complain to complain that
it's hackery I mean your your whole
point I think was that who determines
when it's an interaction unless you're
charged with it unless there's some
finding a fact by a a body that's
objectively examine the issue it's just
one person's supposition or a panel on
CNN or one judge somewhere so I I don't
I don't find any of this persuasive
I don't either look I've given credit to
people on the other side who have
written really thoughtful pieces on why
they believe this is true I don't I
don't agree with it uh there is a
previous uh opinion by Chase saying that
Congress does have to vote but I can't
get beyond the language of the amendment
uh that this is a rebellion and
Insurrection the obvious point of
reference was why the amendment was
written which was the Civil War which
was a real Rebellion now what they're
suggesting is it could be much broader
than that but they give no limiting
principle yeah and that's what makes it
so dangerous yeah they never do um by
the way moving this forward
um Jonathan one of Trump's lawyers is
now suggesting that the attempt to have
him removed from that ballots in 2024
are is potentially tainting a jury pool
is that an argument
I'm sorry can you repeat that we got cut
out for a second yeah just basically
they're saying that the uh
to take him off the ballot that argument
and advancing that is itself potentially
tainting the jury pool is that
persuasive or a reach
well there's to some degree this is all
inevitable right you the problem with
holding all these trials daisy chaining
them before the general election is that
they're all going to be part of the
campaign and that's going to make jury
selection a bloody Nightmare and I still
don't understand why the federal court
recently uh decided to drop her trial
right before super Tuesday at some point
I think mature Minds have got to Prevail
here and to ask how you can make a
defendant run from court to court while
the presidential election is going on
and all of this is going to impact uh
juries which is why much of this should
really go after the election uh bingo
Jonathan my favorite hack out there
Jonathan thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere where else